this is pretty cool hey what is up guys
I'm THD here and I'm here with wired and
today were just looking at awesome gifts
that you can get pretty much anyone you
like we're starting off with the bb-8 by
Spiro it's a toy but it's controlled by
the app on your smartphone so all the
stuff you saw moving forward moving
backwards looking around all of that is
controlled with the app and it even does
cool stuff like respond to your voice so
I think that's with a couple
smartwatches lately and one to consider
is this Samsung gear s2 now it's going
to show you notifications like text
messages and phone calls and calendar
appointments all on your wrist and it
also has this neat bezel around the
edges that clicks sort of like a gear if
you will that allow you interact with
the SmartWatch without actually touching
the display so pretty unique and
definitely a big-ticket item but
something your tech-savvy friend will
like so one thing I do want to mention
is Audio is underrated if you're still
rocking the iPod headphones is probably
time for an upgrade so a dedicated pair
of headphones like this will get you a
big sound upgrade and we'll also have
features like a better design and inline
mic controls and something like this
will actually go over your ear so it'll
stay in your ear for stuff like working
out or moving around a lot so at the end
of the day you have a lot of different
choices for gifts to saw this season
whether it's a toy or an actually
functional piece of tech can't really go
wrong anyway thanks for watching
happy holidays I'll talk to you guys the
next one peace